each other it's a new chapter right well
it seems Megan Markel and print series
new chapter is due to begin any day now
on Sunday the royal family gathered for
Easter service in the Queen's 93rd
birthday but one person was noticeably
absent meanwhile Megan Harry instagrams
a special message for the beloved
matriarch the very pregnant Duchess did
not attend the service but her hubby
Prince Harry did of course Megan is
expected to give birth to baby Sussex
any day now and according to two sources
we now know that her mother Doria
Ragland has arrived in London Megan and
Harry recently moved to Frogmore cottage
near Windsor Castle where they intend to
raise their child this is a very
deliberate move on the Sussex his paw
harry's very keen for baby star six to
be brought up in the countryside but
he's also keen to strike out on his own
while moving amid a pregnancy is no
doubt challenging a source previously
told ET that megan is enjoying her
pregnancy and anticipating the days
ahead
adding quote it is such a happy and
exciting time for megan she looks
absolutely radiant and is taking each
day at a time she is looking forward to
becoming a mother my sources tell me
that actually behind the scenes her and
Harry are really happy at the moment
they're super excited about the spring
birth of their baby according to another
royal source the parents-to-be are
already planning ahead and have
instructed a reputable London agency to
help find a nanny to help them raise
their child the source adds that making
in Harry aren't opposed to an American
nanny and ultimately want what's best
for their child the source explains that
Megan will be a hands-on engaged mother
but she will need help
another source tells ET that Doria will
also play a big part in the new child's
life however no plans are currently in
place for her to make a permanent move
to England the source adds quote Harry
wants making to be happy and will go
along with her wishes
Harry's relationship with William on the
other
seems to be suffering the palace have
tried to knock these rumors of attention
between the four Royals on the head and
it don't seem to be the case that
perhaps they they don't all get along as
well as we thought et has learned that
there was an obvious distance between
the brothers at Sunday's Easter service
the source says that Harry arrived
separate from William and Kate and stood
a distance from his brother when the
Queen arrived remember this is a prince
who spent his entire life in his
brother's shadow and I think in Megan
he's found a new confidence and wants to
move on and be his own person according
to our source the Royals are at
different stages in their life and are
no longer the boys they once were